so let's let's go let's go back to
you know what i recall from our meeting
there
so
the business model of what you did so
one if i remember
that you didn't directly work for the
government because if you did get caught
then it would look like it's the
government so it was a corporation that
you would work for
and and that corporation is who would
send you to go negotiate on behalf of
the u.s government
with not necessarily the bigger
countries it was more smaller uh not
even mid-size we would just say with
smaller countries that you would go to
that had some kind of a natural resource
that america wanted and then the
negotiation was we're going to come and
build some infrastructure we'll invest
some money into your country they'll go
into a [ __ ] ton of debt
then in a way to get money back is
you're going to allow us to build a
military in your country you're going to
give us these resources for 50 cents on
a dollar or 10 cents on a dollar pretty
much for nothing and then if you don't
listen to us we're going to kill you is
that pretty much
explain the business model you followed
yes and yes it is and
so the we're going to kill you part was
i i wasn't going to kill them i never
carried a gun but i knew the guys were
right behind me we called them jackals
they were cias you were talking about
hitmen earlier they'd be in the room
with you while you're having this
conversation no they'd no uh
i suppose i theoretically didn't know
anything about them but who's in the
room with you when you're having these
coverage are you the point man or you're
saying hey here's the deal yeah and
who's with you
i'm probably just meeting one-on-one
with the minister of finance or perhaps
the president you're rolling in solo to
these countries
and having these well no i've got two or
three of the guys who work for me okay
outside they're probably not sitting in
the meeting they might be it they just
depended but but they were there to help
produce the numbers i i was frankly i
was a lousy economist
i was chief economist but i was a good i
was a good talker like i said i was a
good con artist but i knew how to hire
the guys that could crunch the numbers
and come up with these econometric
models that showed how much the country
was going to benefit
that was used to convince the presidents
and they would use it to convince their
people the press in their countries and
so on
you know there was an interesting
cartoon that sort of sums us up as a
uh
that came up many many years ago and it
showed me or an economic hit men
in one hand
holding a fistful of dollars
and saying hey mr president in this hand
i've got a hundred hundreds of millions
of dollars for you and your family if
you buy my deal and then in this hand i
got a gun in case you don't
and that was pretty much it i didn't
have the gun but i knew that the and he
knew because the united states you know
we've admitted to taking out in in in
ending
the life of salvador allende of of chile
uh the shah of iran
uh and most a deck in iran before that
most of the deck particularly
and we didn't really take out the shah
we took out most of the deck lumumba in
the congo zm in vietnam albans and
guatemala and recently 2009 in honduras
president zelaya
so a lot of the activity was in uh
central america south america and then
in the middle east is that or africa
where
or the majority of the countries
anywhere any country that had resources
our corporations coveted that needed
money also well it didn't sound like
iran that didn't really need the money
but we but they needed us to protect
them from russia
and and saudi arabia you know had they
had their reasons but usually it was
countries that needed money had
resources
i focused a lot on latin america because
i'd been there a lot i speak fluent
spanish so it was a it was a it was a
natural for me but i also spent probably
during ten years a year in iran
a lot of time in indonesia so if you
enjoyed this little short segment from
the podcast that we did here's another
short segment to watch or if you want to
see the entire podcast click over here
take care everybody bye-bye
[Music]
you